[音楽]
今日は日本の食糧問題についてちょっと聞いてもらえますか
今日本の食は暗いなんて歌ってほとんど一人はピント県と思います
でも実際にはかなりやばい状況なんですよ
0日本でそんなことないでしょうって思いますよ
皆さんもご存じの通り日本は遅延が少ない国なんで多くのことを外国に伝えています
でも今日本が外国に頼ってるりんは資源が少ないことというがちょっと家なのです
ちょっと前これが原因で o 先に行ったでしょ
新型コロナウイルスの営業で起きた益子パニックです
朝廃炉からドラッグスターの前に帰るがどうかもわからのに8列
できてませんでした
これは踵ね安い中国に依存してたから
チャイマスター
こんなことが職員でおごるかもしれんっていう事を知って欲しくてお話しさせて
いただくことになりました
僕は現在独自産業ポラウナいう仕事させて持っています
これは農林水産省が進める事業で農林水産業の生産者が11
各子会社20
販売サービス業が3時この一次二次三次ロ
掛け算で6次産業でいます
我々プランナーっていうのは一時の生産者が2時3時までお駅通過でできるように
サポートするというのが約0ブーブー特に私はブランディングや販路がいなくだ
関東なって
一陣美人惨事の現場とかなりそこの話をさせています
皆さん今日本の食糧自給率ってどれくらいかご存知です
ちゃんとちゃったの37%しかありません
半分以上外国に立ってて
この数字は年々減ってます
10年後には今の半分くらいになるんちゃうかってそれ
この原因は生産者の高齢化と後継者もそうです
農業も漁業もほんまにお年寄りばかりです
今全国の生産地ではさまざまな問題が発生しています
農業では耕作放棄地っていう体
農業をやめた畑や田んぼがほったらかしんだてない
漁業では敗戦処理もできへんマンは動かんようになったフレーバー
3などに止まったまんまり張ったりしています
僕はこの仕事をする前は百貨店にある水産会社でバイヤーしてました
ちなみにバイヤーっっていうのは
お客さんが喜んでくれそうな商品を探してきてくるっていうのが仕事です
まあわかりやすいうとさかねーーの5000たんです
でも僕は
さカレーの中でもちょっと特殊な仕事を教えたんです
それは産地直送のイベントの企画でした
だからしょっちゅういろんな港へでもいてはどうさん達と直接触れ合って
時には府内おいしながら日本にも投稿させてもうたくしてました
そしてこうした関係ができて初めて
芸術
っていう文を知ったんです
それはこんな海へのに
あんまり儲かってないということでした
よしさんだけじゃなくお薬称賛も
同じですうん
そりゃあもう狩りもせんのに
自分の子や孫に菅したいなんて人おらんでしょ
ボブの親父も余裕でました
後藤ちゃんみたいに
栗全米よーっ
かけ勉強して目がもう行って塩感謝入れてい
寝ながらそれは叶いませんでしたけどねえっ
ちなみに僕の親父は農家の生ポネっ子
心から2
いうことか妙なエール巣立ちました
者から億万する
の頃から食べもず末にしたらちゃくちゃ怒られて食べ物に対する感謝というのは厳しく
しつけられました
僕はっっ
保古3年の冬
オヤジに肝臓がんが見つかりました
ユミル打ちやすべて位
今日はいい
見るのも辛いほどになっていきました
本人も気づいたんでしょうある日
ページが読み暴れだしました
お前は銀なよってたかってひそ分かり嫌がってい
こんなとこで目立って何もの俺やっけって言っ
もういい変えるって言っ
なんとかなるべく良い
しかしつきましたけど
それから親父が名産ますことなく
49歳で
ありました
このころから
スローばっかりあったオヤジに
何も出来んかったことを言いません
をしたい時には上をなし
これってー
の言葉なんじゃないかなって思ってます
そのせいでしょうか
生産現場で必死に働いているお年寄りに出ると親父見ているようなんですよ
だから
なんか事件からっていう想いがあっ
たんでしょうねえ
2011年
東日本大震災が日本を襲って生産業界
ゴロゴロになりました
僕も売る商品初面の2間にプロしてました
そんな時に5
岸和田の漁師さんからシラスが8日取れすぎて相場がたからなってねー
彼の軍団とか何んかーって相談もうたんです
なも食用で売ることできたら高値で売れるっていうことくらいはわかってたんですけど
その方法がわからんだったんですよ
[音楽]
生しらすっていうのは当然ですけど話よりなんかできるわけです
トレイター村まだ状態で食べるっていうことですからね
でも
開成中には目に見えういろんな楽器なんかも見たいします
これを解決せんと百貨店で販売することは止められるのです
それで皆で方法を探すことになりました
そうこうしてると漁師さんが水の処理装置
見つけてきて
試してみることになりました
そして百貨店に計算だしたところあっさり
お外もらえたんだよん
販売戦略をすることになりましたん
メディアに関西百貨店初
朝獲れ生しらす漁職装備ンって
めぐってい
a 4だろう
密着取材が入って上々のスタートが切れました
ちなみにこの時の知らせの相場は1キロ200円
それを僕は600円で c
1500円で販売したところ大ヒットとなって漁師さんも大喜びしてくれました
ん
その後これがきっかけで大阪の漁師さんたちの意識が変わりました
今までは大阪の魚なんてって言われてたけど
ふうしたらた個売れることもわかったし何より
表紙の頭が変わりましたわって言ってくれました
本当に嬉しいことです
ちなみに今では大阪の知らせる押している漁師さんらは皆この装置付て
大阪のシラスはブランドができるようになりました
そしてこの生シラスは水産庁ションを受賞されました
でも僕はっていうと社長にむちゃくちゃ送られて
なんで200円の門600円も出してオートン年ハプちゃう買う前はあっ
でも僕は
会社も十分利益出してお客さんも喜んで毎日予定並んでくれてありますよ
褒められることはあっても怒られる美容何か僕にはわかりませんわって理解してしもう
たんです
そしたら即させな決まってそして
一連を大丈夫することになりました
自分歳もう買った0こんな考え方が
業界をダメにしてるんやなって
お得実感しました
大丈夫は農業にも関わるようになりました
小5軒の農家さんが規格外の一部を有効利用したいっていうことで
関わるようになったんだ
最初でした
春になるとイチゴがたくさん撮れデー
痛みの早い159な売りもんにラールもん
立つなんでいます
これを当時僕が関わっていた金属加工メーカーが取り扱ってた
新風単走
機械で加工したところ
風味豊かなん
ここまではよかったんです
でも実際にはポストが多忙で売れ
同省でられました
それでひょ子べにある有名パティシエさんのところへお願いに上がりました
そしたら快く
協力してくれることになりました
そして苺パウダーをチョコレートに入れる
世界大会出品してくれました
そしたら見事を員賞受賞してくれたんですね
これがきっかけで多くのメディアが取り上げてくれるようになって
この規格外の農産物を活用して
農家の所得を上げる
っていう取り組みは
兵庫県の
今日出る事業になりました
バブル方がいいこう始まったデフレスパイラルでそれまでの日本人の創意工夫するって
言う熱意が減ってしまったように感じています
確かに安打ったら簡単に売れるでしょ
でもそれだけでいいんですか
大昔から続いてきた商売ってそんな得ないように思うんです
お客さんに競泳魚入ったでこれは何が何でも1回食べとき
兄じゃあ
昨日の魚ホンマン惜しかったわ
今日は何がオススメなん
僕が子供の頃ってこんな感じでした
でもスーパーが種類になって
人同士の会話がなくなって人間関係が逆になって
低下が競争ばっかりになってやすい原料を求めて物価の行く以外ここで大量のなって
そのしわ寄せが生産者さん向かって生産者さんが生活できるようになって
生産資産をラー油なってしまってるんです
今現在のお百姓さんの平均命令てー
68歳ですよ
10年後もやっていけると思います
ほんまにこのまま行ったらヤバイんです作る人を撮る人おらんようなってから行ったら
もう手遅れなんですよ
マスクやったら自分でもなんとかなりますけど
肉や魚や野菜すぐにができへんでしょう
けど今やったらまだ間に合うと思うんです
もちろんへ持つクローム誰手間もかかりますわー
売ってる人はそれをちゃんとお客さんに歌ってください
皆さんもそれを認めたってくれませんか
皆さんがそれを認めてた高校てやってくれへんと
大谷口賞賛や表紙さん生活し提携をなるんです
皆さんは一生懸命頑張って作ってリードが作った者と
どこで誰がどんな風に作ったもうわからんと一緒にするんですか
価格さえ安かったらどうでもいいんですか
大阪のある有名な生産者の方がこんなことを撃たれました
甘いだけのもん作るわかんだけど
安全なもんっくんがむちゃむちゃ難しいって言っ
安かろう悪かろう
定価競争ってこんなことなんちゃいます
どこかに無理が出るんです
産地偽装もこうしたことがほとんどの原因でした
こんなことを続けてて持続可能な社会なんて来るんですかねぇ
もうエエ加減こんなぬやめにしませんか
生産者は自分のこだわりやとかプライドを伝えて下さい
売る人はその違いをちゃんと伝えてあってください
そして消費者の皆さんもちょっと米から関心を持ってほしいんです
生産量が少ないから不便な土地誰から採れる量が一定1000円から
うちのお客さんや水門しが海辺ねそんなムリムリイッッ
でけへん言い訳いくらでもできます
でけ言い訳ばっかりしてたって何も変わるんでしょ
言い訳考えている日もあるにあったらできる方法を考えませんか
答えが見つからんかったらてあげて誰かえ方法知りませんかって
a 過去線と聞いた部屋ないすか
結構近くに a子台持ってる人いてるもんです
僕は設定解決してきました
ありがとうございました